The, Pepe has become kind of a symbol
We live in perilous times when it comes to
free speech,
and the threats are coming from both the left
and right.
So we're gonna open up those libel laws folks,
and we're gonna have people sue you like you
never got sued before.
The president has threatened legal action
against the media,
and progressive activists have used violence
to shut down campus speakers they don't like.
In The Los Angeles Times,
former federal prosecutor Ken White shreds
the most popular clichés
used by used by would-be censors
trying to make the rest of us shut the hell
up.
That's technically true,
but the Supreme Court has ruled that those
exceptions are extremely limited.
It’s true that the there are carve outs
for libel, defamation,
true threats of immediate violence, and obscenity.
Page 108, paragraph 3,
no jokes dealing with flatulence, excretion,
urination, ejaculation,
or other bodily functions.
Also note paragraph 2, no use of the so-called
seven dirty words.
These are: cocksucker, motherfucker, fuck,
shit, cunt, cock, and pussy.
But the fact is, that opponents of free speech
have greatly exaggerated the limits to what
we’re allowed to say.
We're irreverent to the point that we're actually
iconoclastic.
And we offend people.
Hate speech, including horrible, ugly, and
stupid statements
is broadly protected.
As Ken White points out,
even outright bigotry isn't exception to the
First Amendment.
There might be a philosophical case for this
position,
but there's no legal one.
The courts don't do cost/benefit analyses
on specific speech acts.
And if the speech doesn't fall into a prohibited
category, you can't stop it.
This widely misquoted line by Supreme Court
Justice Oliver Wendel Holmes, Jr.
has often been used as a justification for
censorship.
As Ken White points out, speech is only prohibited
if it’s
“intended and likely to provoke imminent
lawless action.”
So if you see someone getting ready to throw
a tomato
knock the crap out of them, would yeah?
Seriously.
Fact is that over time the Supreme Court has
only expanded free speech.
Even cases involving videos of animals being
tortured
or the Westboro Baptist Church’s demonstrations
at military funerals
have yielded solid 8-to-1 majorities in favor
of free speech.
If today's calls for suppressing speech teach
us anything,
it's that we can never take the First Amendment
for granted.
Even if the Supreme Court is on our side,
free expression will only continue to exist
for as long as we’re willing to make it ourselves.